I'm mark Bustos and I'm gonna show you
how to achieve a bang or a fringe we
like to call it sometimes the best
candidate for a fringe or bang is
someone with a receding hairline
not that you're hiding your receding
hair but you're just using what you have
to work with your desired look this
product is a great daily refresher
it's a deep-sea foundation mist and it's
actually got some minerals and some
saltwater and it gives it a little bit
of that natural saltwater texture to it
so what we want to do is hold your hair
up off of this base so that it creates
some some layering and as it drops
you'll have shorter pieces and through
here I know gradually drop longer
because otherwise if I cut it straight
through this way you can get more of
that one bang you're going to see that
it falls into almost like a point or a V
coming towards the front when it's cut
this way we'll be able to wear it either
to the left or to the right I'll be able
to wear all different ways the best way
to go about styling it's really just
blow-dry it back and forth left and
right this hair naturally wants to grow
over to the right if you look at it you
can see the natural direction of growth
in his hair so if we blow-dry it in the
opposite direction you're going to get
that lift you get a nice broken up
weakened look where you can get a nice
classic
tight shape to it once the hair has been
dry I like using this cream called Kingo
feather and starting in the back working
your way forward again I like to do the
front last because the front is where
you touch your hair the most throughout
the day with your naturally oily hands
once we've done that we can comb it down
into place you can start off by bringing
it in the direction his hair naturally
grows into it
see how that looks and we're working
with the fringe you want to put all your
attentions towards just the very front
but don't be afraid to work it in
through up here as well so it all flows
in together you can also just flip it
around the other way and get a little
bit more lift and a different look on
texture